There's a sort of a funny saying which
is that whenever people are are free to
choose anything they want,
they usually choose what their friends
have chosen.
This mimicry that we humans events is
extremely fundamental.
Therefore,
networks provide us a kind of
mathematical,
social and biological tool to understand
the kind of fundamental basis for this
mimicry because you copy the people to
whom you are connected primarily and
you'll come to copy them along the whole
variety of traits in the workplace.
These traits might include things like
how energized you are at work or a how
innovative you are at work or how
cooperative you are at work or whether
you smoke or not.
Our other health traits,
all of these desirable properties,
your productivity,
your innovativeness,
your cooperativeness,
your health come to depend upon the like
attributes in individuals to whom you're
connected.
Our group and other groups have mapped
networks in the workplace,
have come to understand how people are
connected to each other and have used
that understanding as a kind of
mechanism or tool and opportunity for
intervention in order to call forth from
people.
I'm better behavior if you will.
More cooperativeness,
more innovativeness,
a more um,
collaborativeness and better health
behaviors.
The usual way of understanding workplace
organization is the classic Org Chart
where you have boxes and names and it's
like a tree,
um,
but actually the real work or the
reorganization of a workplace looks
nothing like that.
It's the way people interact with each
other.
It's a more jumble of ties.
It looks more like a jumble of Christmas
tree lights.
So if you can think of a network as
every note,
every person is a little light and the
wires connecting them are the ties
between them.
And when you take out a jumble of
Christmas tree lights and you put it on
the floor and look at it actually,
that's what workplace networks really
look like.
Once you understand those patterns of
interactions,
you can begin to understand how people
influence each other with respect to
health and health behaviors in the
workplace.
And once you understand that pattern of
interactions and that pattern of
influence,
you can begin to think about ways of
intervening in it.
For example,
you can identify influential individuals
within the network and target them with,
with health.
Um,
interventions or you can identify ways
to get groups of people to sign up for
interventions and we know that when
groups of people,
particularly people who know each other
and are interconnected collaboratively
engage in something such as a health
improvement behavior,
that they're more likely to sustain it
and more likely to respond positively.
So once you understand the structure of
human interactions,
it opens up all kinds of new vistas,
new ways that you can intervene.